all right diamond hi mark hey Devin
round two we're gonna try again we're
going round two so let's start from the
top - tell me where'd you grow up I grew
up actually between Tasha tree one
second between Josh dr. Valley baby let
me call you back over like interview let
me call you back up in the middle my
interview I'm in middle my interview let
me call you guys see there's mark all
right sorry I grew up in Josh Street
Dhaka Valley really that's why did my um
adolescent years my elementary that's
the elementary she we suck Elvira for my
kiddie car graduation I was only black
in the whole school my family was coming
back you know community at the time how
was your childhood well and she didn't
start really happy too bad - me too I'd
say about seven cuz before that she I
was too young to realize anything
everything was still Google Gaga yeah
mom and dad mom and dad momma Dee I was
high school sweethearts they have a it's
nine of us all together it's I'm the
oldest hard iron
eight girls in one boy though
dysfunctional mom's alcoholic dad was a
crack crack addict but very talented and
smart my dad was a sighted person today
he play any instrument you know his his
parents was wealthy so his own child so
he got everything has him like he was
posted on the other hand you know I
guess he just took his to use his smarts
he didn't use we you know he did
opposite with his life so it turned out
the way did or whatever but you know to
prison every time my dad came home from
jail
there was a baby being made before the
baby was born he was already gone
you know my mom was the hustler in the
family she took care of us she did our
charity to make sure
we had the best everything as me she did
whatever what kind of kid were you in
high school I didn't like school I was
all rested by a high supply my son came
what age were you when he started I
started at 13 13 you neighbors with a
pimp
no on your own yeah at 13 I was
intrigued by the outside of the dress-up
you know you know the dress up in the
the money and the fantasy part of it I
had no idea what was headed for me and
store for me
do you recall your first time yeah I
know what first time I remember I like
15 cars seen by before I got in the
first car and the first car picked me up
he was doctor he deliver babies for a
living I'll never forget it he lived in
a gated community
Huggle Hills and I'm never going up the
hill way up in the violence and we got
he wanted me to [ __ ] on him and I didn't
know what he meant defecate and I'm like
I'm 13 I'm like what the [ __ ] is
defecated I have no every skill so I
have nothing I don't know what I'm doing
but defecate was one where I did not
know and he looked at me he said you've
never done this before and I go well it
doesn't matter I'm here now he gave me
those dollars and told me to leave I had
took me down or six hours walking back
down that hill to get to the back to the
entrance nobody paid me ever since then
I've hooked
$1000 13th I was like a million host me
at that time
[ __ ] I ain't stop talking sense so
you've been doing this for how long now
28 years now I'll be 44 next one how do
you think his lifestyle has changed you
[ __ ] I can't even save it change me now
cuz I've been in so long it's like what
I know what does it change your street
smarts your intuition must be very keen
yeah well III say I have good street
smarts because I studied it really
because in the beginning I was I heard
thinking I knew it all but I getting I
was really scared but I never showed
fear because you know you just can't
always let us funny clever one make sure
not to show fear you show fear didn't
that makes you the belly
the beasts that gives him upper hand so
if you act like you're not scared it
might help you a little bit I don't know
it's hard to explain its life mark
because you know you have to be really
strong person to build in endure this
life you know everybody can't do it you
know first of all man and female strong
and weak you know for you to jump in the
chorus why you don't know have no no
careful sorry about being hurt or so the
bad happens to you man you got to be
really strong minded person you got to
[ __ ] have you got to have something
besides yourself like I love power like
a god with you to be able to do that
because it's not easy because everybody
can't do it I don't what the friends you
know realize the money I was making it
seen how much I was making everything
and want to do it but they just couldn't
do it
you know they getting a crowd like
feasel get scary you know to say or how
to say it
you know I think it's all about
communication most men are easy that's
the good part about this job you know we
know what a man wants you know and they
only think one thing at a time
and all you got to do is do one thing
that's dress it up once you dress it up
and show up they're gonna follow you
know and your powers in your hand really
most girls don't loli worse or no [ __ ]
they weren't prepared the only worth you
don't know actually there's not a dollar
in the world that could actually pay for
what I have to give you it's not enough
money the world for it for it but it's a
price on okay you know I try always
think big you know cuz I don't like to
get small I got too many habits you know
shopping oh I love to go watch it
I love playing dress-up you know now I
got a drug problem that's another habit
you know and that's not cheap hmm it's
crack your drug yes it is and that's
what we how long used crack uh I was 26
my first time my first good right hmm
you know they like that first no it was
like a weekend thing with um you know
friends and we did on the weekends you
know and then I was it but then I got to
realize and [ __ ]
this takes away a lot of my [ __ ] prop
I smoked this she ate I don't think
about
all [ __ ] are going on you know I'll
think about nothing but you know I don't
care foot Adsit
so I still kind of like got me mainly in
the beginning it's not so much my drug
now because its first of all it's not
the same it's they don't give me the
highlight used to so I'll do more
drinking and once all the weeds and I do
nowadays you know because practically
girls it used to be so it's not worth
your volume really it's not working
you're doing and the people that come
with it nowadays it makes it no fun so I
don't really bother too much more um
I'll get my drink on have you had bad
experiences working the street oh my god
that experience you're deaf a lot of
times you not get more words my work
experience this was before the streets
you know I seven I was cetera zone when
I first got my lesson right you know
that was more horrible to me then i
trick picking me up in and i guess they
call it rape I don't call her call it
come was a child you know I get in a car
you know I feel like rapist like when he
snatched you up take you off and do
something about your wheel well you
actually volunteer to get in a car for
some money and it go bad that's just
[ __ ] part of job that's how I feel
you know I just come to church for me
out you know I like alright I don't call
them that it's impossible for a whole
week all to getting raped I don't
understand it you volunteered yourself
for this [ __ ] so that's what it is you
know you been arrested before how I've
been arrested yeah whatever work they're
not a second aim is to be jail that's
also preserved
how many times roughly my first time I
did 12 years oh really yeah and I just
did not just use discuss any of that
altogether
I said I gave the presence all my
twenties and half my thirties I thought
saw what was Irv's I look good for 44
and I gotta make it walk this long
prison terms are for what uh numerous
things because I didn't come on using
drugs I came out here you know fast
money you know fast life
oh hell no but I was you know partitions
will got me involved with things I get
involved with you know that's the baby
can put out there you know you meet
people that you you don't think you're
imagining to me you know prostituting
you know let's see it push yourselves
I'm Evy but Donald Trump go come by so
one day yes I'm saying so you meet
people all [ __ ] a life and I've always
been open to a pop see you know cuz I
feel like I'm the greatest thing you
know out here so you know obviously
either be in my presence
cuz I love one thing I'm not a I'm not a
hindrance in everyone ever asked that
far it's just on her so even if you
don't like me or let me it cuz you know
that's money you know I come I might be
reduce you to somebody that you couldn't
get introduced to prior to meet me
what's your favorite personality trait
about yourself I love all of me really I
can't say it's not about me I like just
want bad feet right now cuz Carla buyers
only my female
confidence is a good quality have well I
mean I've been chewed all my life I was
born cheap so you know I can't you know
they called me a lot of things they
can't call me ugly cuz that's how I
wasn't born ugly sometimes I can act
ugly but you have to bring out in me
they just don't out likely show I have
very good people skills and I'm a very
good manipulator are you sometimes
tricking guys out of money you're trying
to figure out how much money that he got
and trying to get it that's my job strip
got your money
my job is not to do it yes sometimes
people think it's as simple as you
having sex for money
high usually trying to get the money out
of the guy I very rarely have sex I I
have what you call goes [ __ ] I promise
you dreams I so you promised his and you
buy because long as I look like I look
the part you're gonna buy it all you
know it's not hard to dress up and and
to put her face on and to be somebody
else
I call myself I carry case Sandra Lucci
on my children
that's a call [ __ ] but she baby she
probably shoot all of [ __ ] the
land all everything and donkeys ship at
a hard time
it have you been in love before huh have
you been in love oh [ __ ] I better list I
could ever love twice and I love was in
love because it was it felt different
you know anytime a man was around you
and once better for you and to want you
just do good things in your life and
it's not allow you to keep going down
the road that you were in when he met
you
any times my comfort like to help you
improve is love people that come to life
to help you to help you harness yourself
or to help you just integrate that's not
luck I don't know I think you got to
love yourself little bit here fine
enough and you don't look no you don't
come anywhere all over yourself you come
in the world with the world [ __ ] with
Rory things you ought to learn that they
have to be with in living this lifestyle
has gotta make it hard for romantic
relationships this lifestyle for beach
chairs like sushi because even if you do
like so much my likes you saw his back
and remind you a hoe games like what
might better pay me so it's our media
relations their time I watch their time
you touch me I want you to use money I
don't care if you are boy for especially
if your boyfriend your boyfriend wants
money what advice would you give to a
young girl who's considering doing this
no you know
damn I want I want to see my kids but if
it's a girls are already doing it
involved I try to show them which what
to do a lot would like to do to keep
them such a survive but my advice is
just try something else
don't do it it's dangerous this
lifestyle and the more the years ago by
gets worse you know there's nothing easy
about this [ __ ] that I really know y'all
[ __ ] you got to really know what you're
doing to survive out here in this life
like you'll be [ __ ] up toe up fast
fast those predators out there I mean
real like predators people I thought
just come out to harm to her with bad
intentions you know I got um grocers did
a lot of girls I started wetting the
game he not even here now they're
literally dead or in prison for life
make it bad chasing the bad choices
where do you see your life going from
here who knows I was I can't you see the
future
but I can't all I see is ten toes down
all right I need to be done done all
right John thank you so much for talking
[Applause]
you